- [Voiceover] Right over
here we have the graph of F
and then we have four
different expressions.
What I encourage you to
do is pause this video
and see if you can
figure out which of these
expressions would give
the largest quantity,
the second largest quantity, the second
smallest quantity and
the smallest quantity.
I'm assuming you have paused the video
and you have given an attempt.
Now let's work through this together.
This first expression right over here,
we're taking the sum from
I equals zero to nine.
We're actually taking
the sum of 10 things,
because we're taking
the zero thing, first,
second, third, all the way up to nine.
So this is actually going
to be the sum of 10 things
because we're starting at zero.
We start at F of negative five plus zero.
We're saying negative five,
F of negative five plus zero.
That's this height right over here.
That's that height right over there.
We're going to take that,
and then when I equals one
it's going to be negative five plus one,
which is negative four.
It's that height right over there.
Then negative five plus
two when I equals two.
It's going to be that
height right over there.
We're essentially going
to sum up all the way.
This is going to be negative five,
negative five all the way up to, negative
five plus nine is going to
get us all the way to four.
It's going to be all the way over there.
All the way over there.
You might be guessing,
"Well, how do I relate this?
"They've already kind of made us think
"that we're going to somehow relate this
"to area somehow, but how do we
"actually make that relationship?"
Because right now, as this is written,
it's just giving us essentially a bunch
of the values of the
functions at different points.
I guess you could say it's a lot
of these heights, right over here.
But one thing that might jump out at you
is you could construct
rectangles, all that have
width one, and so if
you multiply the height
times the width, the area is going to be
the same thing as the height.
If we put a one times one right over here,
this makes it very
clear that you're taking
the height times the
width of this rectangle
and then this rectangle.
You essentially have
a bunch of left-handed
rectangles that you could imagine are
trying to estimate this bluish
area that was shaded in.
It's clearly going to be an underestimate,
because it's giving up these areas.
It's giving up those
areas, right over there.
All of these rectangles are sitting,
they're either just touching or they are
below the actual function.
Let me just write this right over here.
This is going to be an underestimate
of the area of this blue area.
Now let's think about
what this one is, here.
This is F, it's the same thing
that we're taking the sum of.
We're starting at I equals
one and we're going to 10.
Once again, 10 things.
Negative five plus one is negative four.
F of that is this line, right over here.
Is that line right over there.
It looks like we're taking
right-handed rectangles,
because you could say times one,
times one would be the area.
Obviously, if we multiply
by one, we're not
changing the value of this expression.
That would be the area of this
first right-handed rectangle.
Then when I is equal to
two, it's going to be
F of negative three, and so you're
looking at this one right over here.
I can, let me draw at
least this part of it.
It's going to look something like this.
It's going to look something like this,
where now we're dealing with right-handed
rectangles, and these are
clearly an overestimate.
These are right-handed rectangles.
You're going to go all the
way, when I is equal to 10,
negative five plus 10 is five F of five.
That's this line right over here,
or this length right over here, F of five.
Of course, we're multiplying it by one.
It's going to look like that,
and we could keep going.
I think you get the general idea now.
These are all going to be right-handed
or these are all right handed
rectangles that I've drawn.
These are going to be an
overestimate of the area,
because they all have this little extra,
they all have this extra
region, right over here.
These are going to be an overestimate.
Now let's think about
this one, right over here.
This is, we're going to
start at I equals one
and we're going to go to 20.
It looks like we're going to do rectangles
instead of width one, we're
going to width one half.
Once again, since we're
starting at I equals one,
these look like right-handed
rectangles again.
This is, that we're
going to use to estimate.
Let me do this in a color
that you can actually see.
I'll do this in orange.
I'll do this in orange right over here.
The first one is going to be
negative five plus one half.
It's going to be this, F
of that, which is going
to take you right over there.
Then you're going to multiply
it times the width, which is one half.
Now we have twice as many, twice as many
right-handed rectangles.
It's going to look like this.
Twice as, and I won't do all of them
because it takes some time.
We're going to have twice as many
right-handed rectangles.
It's still going to be an overestimate,
but it's going to be
less of an overestimate
than this one over here.
Because this one over here, you had all
of this extra green
space above the function.
Now we have a lot less extra space,
a lot less extra space above the function.
It's a better estimate, but it's still
going to be an overestimate,
because at least
for this function right over here,
because at least over this interval
where the function is increasing,
the right-handed rectangle
is giving us an overestimate.
But this is a little bit more precise
because we're using narrower
rectangles to estimate.
Overestimate but less so, but less so
than this one right over here.
This right over here, this
is a definite interval,
from negative five to five of F of X, DX.
You can imagine, this
is essentially the limit
as we take these widths to be smaller
and smaller and smaller.
We essentially end up having
essentially an infinite number.
We approach an infinite number
of these right over here.
This is the actual area.
This is what's actually depicted in blue.
If I were to list this
from largest to smallest.
The biggest overestimate, this is
the biggest overestimate,
right over there.
This is still going to be an overestimate
but it's a little bit more precise
because we have more rectangles.
I'll put that two.
This is the actual area.
I'll put that three.
Then this is actually an underestimate.
I would rank this four.
This is the largest of the values,
and this is going to be
the smallest of the values.